hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
name is rich roll
i am your host and today returning for
his
third appearance on the show is my
friend dr rangan chatterjee
rangan is one of the uk's most high
profile pioneers in functional
integrative medicine he's also a fellow
swim run fanatic
and this is a really fun conversation
beyond his
medical practice rangan hosts the feel
better live more podcast
he's the best-selling author of a slew
of books and
the primary focus subject of today's
conversation
is his latest tome feel better in five
which is
really all about adopting small and very
simple
digestible habits to forge sustainable
lifestyle change
if you're digging my stuff and this
channel in general please hit that
subscribe button
as well as the little notification bell
so you're properly alerted
every time we drop a new video i really
appreciate it
alright let's do it this is me and dr
rangan chatterjee
wrong and my friend good to see you back
for your third turn on the podcast
my only regret being we're not in the
same room but
be it as it may this is the world that
we live in right now
so i'll take any opportunity i can to
connect with you my friend good to have
you today
yeah thanks rich yeah me too man i would
have loved to be in
with you in person but this is as good
as it gets but i'm sure we're still
gonna have a great conversation
nonetheless
yeah so i want to get into the new book
of course congrats on it just being
released in
the united states but before we do that
like how's it going
in the uk i talked to a friend of mine
who lives in london two days ago
and he said by by what he related to me
it sounded like things were
a little bit more normal there than they
are here in los angeles
what's the day-to-day yeah look i think
the way we're reacting to this is so
individual isn't it that you can talk to
10 different people about
their perception how they're feeling
about the world
and you may get 10 different answers
certainly you'll get five or six
different answers and so what's going on
here
well you know people are still worried
people are still wearing masks out and
about
um there's a there's a big divide as to
what people actually
think is really going on which is really
interesting to observe
on an individual level my children went
back to school today you know
wow uh which i i don't know what's going
on with you guys but you know my two
kids who were 10 and seven
we dropped them off at school for the
pretty much one of the first times in
five months so
it was yeah it was interesting just
getting back to
what used to be normal for many parents
around the country
um i tell you what was different this
today it was quite odd actually after
having had the kids
around for so long
i really miss them you know i really
miss them in the day when i knew they
weren't here so
um yeah that's kind of a little snapshot
as to what's going on
that's nice our kids are doing exactly
what we're doing right now
they're on zoom all day for their school
and it's really
taken a toll like the mental drain of
them having to you know receive their
education
through a screen entirely is you know as
you know not the healthiest thing in the
world
and it's been tricky as a parent to help
them
navigate that the emotional you know
mental
turmoil that it causes to have them
separated from their friends and to have
their childhood in certain respects
stripped away from them
has been really trying it's encouraging
to hear that your kids are back in
school i wish that was the case here but
it's not yeah and you you i mean you
i think certainly from what we read
about what's going on in the u.s
uh things seem to be quite different
there from what i can tell and
you know watching a little bit a little
bit you know
and it's i don't know it's really tricky
rich because
in terms of how people see this i think
it really depends
on who you are and what's your situation
so for some people
the pandemic honestly has provided a
wonderful opportunity for people to
re-evaluate their lives reset what's
important
spend more time with people who they're
close to whether it's their partner or
their family
but for other people they've had the
complete opposite experience of
worry financial hardship
potentially losing their job potentially
losing a family member or a close friend
to illness you know maybe having a
funeral that you couldn't go to
because of the regulation so i really
feel that this has been one of those
times where
our reaction is so individual you know
and i think it depends on what media you
consume you know are you intentionally
consuming
lots of mainstream media and i think if
you are potentially
you may struggle with anxiety or stress
with the state of the world and then if
you shut yourself off
you can sometimes feel really good in
yourself
but potentially starts become detached
with what's actually going on out there
so i think it's quite a challenging
um it's been a challenging time to to
for people to navigate and
you know before our conversation today i
was thinking back to when the pandemic
started
i was in la as this was
i remember about i was about to come to
your house just to meet
not for a podcast you know as part of
what i'm trying to do these days is
really trying to prioritize
connecting with people who i enjoy
connecting with and it was one of those
where it's like oh maybe
me and rich could get together and not
do a podcast and just
i'm hanging out
entire relationship is oriented around
podcast conversations
but i saw the text message about an hour
ago and it literally it was on a
thursday you said yeah we'll touch base
tomorrow morning
and i thought i'm coming to your place
and then
literally on that friday everything
changed yeah um
you know yeah yeah it's it's weird it's
strange
uh certainly anxiety depression suicidal
ideation loneliness all of these things
are
are peaking right now certainly in
america and across the world so
what are you seeing with your patients
how are they
navigating it what's showing up in your
office these days
yeah um i exactly what you said i think
the mental health
consequence of this pandemic
is not only huge at the moment
i think we're yet to see the impacts of
it and and i
i really think there is a
you know so how can i put this you've
got
the situation where you know the the
authorities are making decisions
based on uh what they think is going to
save
immediate acute lives right
and they're measuring that with daily
you know daily death rates things that
are easily measurable from day to day
right but on the other hand you've got
the chronic consequences
of this lack of human contact this lack
of face-to-face connection the fact that
people aren't congregating anymore the
people are feeling isolated
resentment is starting to build up in
people relationships are under pressure
under strain
and a lot of those things are more
chronic they're not quite as easy to
measure
and yes anxiety is going up
stress-related problems are going up
suicides are going up i've you know in
the last few weeks heard some
really horrible stories not just from my
patients but really tragic ones in
my friend network and my family network
as well in terms of
nothing to do with actually you know
coronavirus per se
but actually to do with how we're now
living
um you know schools i think certainly
here in the uk they're open but
what is the impact going to be on these
children
in three four five years time of having
at a very formative
part of their life they're sort of
almost being told
whether consciously or not they're
subconsciously getting the message
that oh i must be wary off the other you
know i can't get too
close and i i that is one of my big
concerns about this
is the consequence of this um i've
spoken to
and i think last time i was on your show
we spoke about touch
and a lot of professor francis mcglone's
research
on human touch and just how important it
is
for our emotional brain and the signals
we
get when we are touched by another human
and that is something that many people
have missed out on and i tell you rich
my mother who's she's going to be 80 in
a week's time she lives about five
minutes away from me
and right at the start of lockdown she
had a fall
and i remember it really well because it
was probably in the first week or two
when
nobody quite knew what was going on like
it was like
what's happening to the world and i went
round
and i didn't want her to be admitted i
thought i don't want her going in a
hospital right now
so i ended up staying with her for a few
nights on the floor
next to her bed just to make sure she
was okay just to make sure everything
was all right and she didn't need to go
in
and you know so she was quite frail and
and quite
um just quite affected by it by a few
weeks
but it was really interesting a few
weeks later she has someone who comes
around maybe
for you know an hour a day to help with
some cooking and a few things at home
and i remember she phoned me one day and
she said
you know what i'm over this i i can't
live like this i would rather
and i'm not at all suggesting that
anyone else should feel like this i'm
just talking about an individual
story this is my mum she said you know
what i'd rather take my chances i'd
rather get this
virus and if i don't make it i don't
make it but i can't live like this not
seeing anyone not seeing my family
not seeing my friends and it really
struck me early on rich that
there's two sides to this there's the
acute side and the chronic side and
actually that's
that's that's the theme we've spoken
about before right whether it's
health problems the acute problem like
the pneumonia which
western medicine does beautifully well
at versus the chronic consequences of
the lifestyles that we lead
and you can actually draw the same
analogy
in the pandemic there is an acute
consequence
potentially um and there's a chronic one
and the chronic one is the one
i don't think is getting factored into
decision making because
you know we can kick the can down the
road it's like oh we can't quite see
that
although i think we are starting to see
it but we can't quite see it and measure
it
in the same way so i'm i'm concerned i'm
really concerned about children really
you know i
i think you know humans are social
beings we're
designed to be together and to thrive in
community
and i i really i worry
about the impact on kids in the future
if i'm honest yeah it's very real
uh i can see it in my 13 year old
daughter
when we do venture out into the world
which isn't often
she's very trepidatious about it and
she's more diligent about mask wearing
when she's outside the house than
probably anybody else in
in our house and it's left me reflecting
on
what the long-term implications of that
relationship with how you interact with
the world
are going to be like what is the
half-life
of that fear response when
you're in the presence of another
individual as opposed to
embracing the world and looking forward
to those social interactions entering
each one of those
with that kind of sense of
potential doom what does that
set in motion for that person's life
five years down the line 10 years down
the line if they can't get over it i
think there's going to be
a post-traumatic stress response to this
that we're going to see
you know amongst mostly young people and
what that's going to look like i think
only time will tell but i think it's a
very real concern
and i think on top of that you know this
is something that you're
well versed in the health of our immune
system
is related to the extent to which we
interface with
not just the natural world but the
social world like our
immune systems become more robust the
more that we're in contact with other
human beings
that's part of what what it's about in
terms of maintaining
our immune systems and now we're being
sequestered
we're prevented from that interface what
does that mean
you know it's all very confusing and
disorienting and that's all exacerbated
by
this variation in in
the kind of information that we're
receiving these different narratives
about what we should and should not be
doing that are causing vitriol and
strife and
really dividing us in a profound way
yeah it is and i can hear it in your
voice it's um
it's weighing you know and you've it's
interesting you mentioned your 13 year
old daughter
my son's 10 and i would guess that the
jump from 10 to 13 is significant my son
is still in primary school i still
feel that he is relatively sheltered
from the wider world i suspect
that when one goes to i don't know what
you call it in the states here secondary
school or high school you know basically
from 11 plus
i suspect things are very different and
i can't imagine what it's like for a 13
year old because at that age you know
you're all about your friends and
hanging and sort of
almost pushing back against your family
and actually really trying to get your
own
tribe what does that do what will that
mean for relationships in five
ten years time i i've you know i know i
think you might charles eisenstein on
early on didn't you yeah i mean i
remember i still remember
reading his essay you know
the coronation essay yeah which was just
a brilliant read when i read it at the
time i've not actually i've not
revisited it i made it
but i remember that the thing which
really struck me the end of it was when
he said
um he said something like
it depends how you see
life as a society if you value the
preservation
of life above everything else
then certain measures make sense if you
value the quality
of life then perhaps we need to have a
slightly different conversation and
you know i appreciate that this is super
emotive for people so i'm i'm not
i'm just trying to as a philosophical
point i really
i haven't been able to get that out of
my head since i read it
what is the what is the society
what does society look like how do we
want to live
uh because you know that there is an
element of risk to being alive right the
way to be completely safe from anything
is to
well you stay at home don't interrupt
that never get it don't
never get in the car never do anything
yeah yeah don't go running on a trail
right you did you you know don't do any
of those things where you could
potentially
run into problems but then the flip side
is what what
if we think about the fun things in life
if i think about my own you know the
last
couple years you know getting into ocean
swimming swim running
you know before that skiing
you know it's the element of danger
but it's almost in so many ways actually
basically tells you how much of a puzzle
you're going to get afterwards you know
if of course you can have fun without an
element of danger
but it almost reminds you in that moment
wow i am alive
what an amazing feeling i am alive
and i just feel that the thing that
frustrates me rich if i'm honest is i
don't
feel there's been enough of a public
conversation around the long-term
consequences i think we
and i get that you know i get that
there's there's this thing which we've
never seen before we've never seen these
sort of lockdowns and there's a
short-term focus but i really think the
time is just we really need to start
thinking about the long-term
consequences
but we're also not seeing with a
mainstream narrative
we're not seeing a focus on what the
immune system is
and how we can start supporting it you
know
it and i find it bizarre that we've not
had
more of it in terms of i know you spoke
to um dr b
recently and you know he was talking
about the immune system
and you know there are so many things
that we can do
that will support our immune system you
know getting seven and a half hours
sleep a night compared to
five hours for example has been shown to
change
the amount of natural killer cells in
your body
by 50 60 percent right what are natural
killer cells
they are the part part of your innate
immune system
that fight viruses right so
of course it's a novel virus to many
people
right that's that's what we're being
told but
you've got to you've got to say well why
don't we help people boost up
uh support their immune system so that
even if they get exposed
they're more resilient the diet the
quality of the food people are eating
the amount of different colored plants
these things help to educate your immune
system and that's
a key word which you mentioned before
the education of our immune system
the immune system you know when we're
born we have we're not completely
sterile actually we we do have a few
bugs
inside us but um you know we get our gut
microbiome
which is a big part of our immune system
it's very much interlinked with the
immune system from our mothers
but then what happens well living being
in life being exposed to new foods being
exposed to things in the environment
that helps give your immune system
signals and your immune system is very
clever it responds ah
okay it tries to figure out when i
should respond
and when i should actually stay calm and
stay quiet and it it it is very
frustrating
that we've not been able to have that
conversation and people who do
speak up about that what is then
happening is that people are
jumping on them which is reflective of
the way of the world at the moment
and saying you're devaluing the social
distancing measures and it's like well
hold on a minute
it's not either all you don't have to
choose either you follow the guidelines
or you ignore them and look after your
immune system well why not do both
why not say hey guys we would recommend
this societally
but individually we know that if you can
do these three or four things
sleep better stress less move your body
eat better
you're actually going to support your
immune system why why is that
conversation not happening yeah because
it doesn't feed
the mainstream media fear narrative
you know and it's particularly
concerning when
what we are coming to understand about
this novel virus
and the impact the disproportionate
negative impact that it has on people
with comorbidity factors like the more
unhealthy you
are it appears the more you know at risk
you are
in terms of the severity of what you're
going to endure
should you come in contact with the
virus it's been very strange in los
angeles in the early stages of the
quarantine
they closed all the they close the
beaches like everybody knows but they
also close like all the trails and i can
understand
closing certain trails that are heavily
trafficked but they were closing
all these tiny little trails that i felt
like i only knew about where i would go
out running and
i'd be the only person out there and
there'd be
yellow police tape around it all of a
sudden and i i was thinking
this is perhaps one of the healthiest
things that i could do right now
i'm socially distant i'm not going to
see anybody and yet i'm being prevented
from doing this thing that i think is in
the best interest of
making sure that i'm in a good healthy
position should i encounter the virus
yeah and there's you know there's
there's a wider point as well which many
people have been thinking about
which and i have as well because you
know we live in a society where there
are certain rules these there's
there's rules of engagement to allow
society to function
in a certain way you know it's not the
wild west where anything goes
but many people i know myself included
if i'm honest a little bit
were very much like oh i can't go in the
countryside now i like i can't go
into nature and then you then you start
to think philosophically well who owns
nature like is it possible to
legislate that a human can't
go into nature and i look i understand
i'm not saying there aren't
reasons for it i'm just saying that if
you extend these arguments
to that sort of to their extreme
it is it was i thought hold on a minute
i feel very frustrated that i
i can't go here and actually go for a
run here or
um but but i understand also the flip
side right so i'm i'm not sort of
saying oh you know poor wrong and he
couldn't do what he wanted to do no i
get it that there's a societal
issue at play but uh but these
like many people make the the a lot of
these thoughts have been going round
and round my heads um and you you go
one you know one week you're feeling
really good and you're feeling
totally okay with things and then
another week you're sort of feeling
a little bit tensed up and down and i
think maybe four or five months in there
was this
general feeling in the uk that people
were just thinking
i've had enough now i've had enough now
i just need to get out and express
myself
in whatever way so i you know you
mentioned the news narrative as well and
it was interesting
because at the start of this you know i
would you know
the day i was meant to see you i flew
back from la that evening
and i think so i got back to the uk on
saturday i think i was on bbc news on
the monday
uh talking about uh what was going on i
really felt a public service obligation
at the start i thought
a lot of people certainly in the uk
trust me
and want to see what i have to say about
so i really felt
responsibilities to go on but then after
a few weeks i thought these are all
quite negative stories and i
i wouldn't mention which station it was
but i did suggest should we do a
positive piece around this
and there just wasn't that much interest
and i
really started to see oh okay kind of so
there's a certain story and a narrative
that
certainly people are either wanting or
media
companies are wanting to put out and i
i went for a period of two months and i
didn't go actually i just thought you
know what
i feel that every time i go on
you know and they're taking um questions
from the audience
and the guidance at the time was
literally changing every single day
and a lot of the guidance didn't make
sense and it was in conflict to the
previous guidance and
i just thought you know what my kids are
at home
my wife probably was quite anxious at
the start so we have a very different
view to this i've been pretty relaxed
throughout most of this
um my wife on the other hand has got
quite anxious from time to time
and i've learned that it's not fair of
me to expect her to look at the
situation like me it's about to try to
understand no this is
real in her head this is how she feels
and i need to sit there and try and
listen to that and be there and support
and i was finding that i was getting
really stressed out about going on the
media
to talk about a negative story
that's why i just stopped doing it and
you know what i i found myself happier
karma having more fun with the children
getting more work done and it it's been
it's been a such an intense period that
i think we've experienced so many
emotions
but they've been supercharged like the
highest of highs and the lowest of lows
i don't know would you say that's the
same for you rich yeah everybody's on a
hair trigger it's being fueled by the
fear narrative and the anxiety and the
stress and the
economic insecurity like all of these
things are very real and just to be
very clear myself like i'm conducting
myself like a good citizen
i'm wearing a mask when i go out and you
know go
inside to any kind of retail
establishment i mean all i do is go to
the grocery store essentially unless i'm
home or doing the podcast but
i'm respecting the protocols that you
know that are being
advised in terms of social distancing
etc um
meanwhile i'm also taking care of myself
and trying to put myself in the best
position to
to manage all of this and i've been also
on that
sine wave of feeling fine and then
having moments of
of depression and despair that kind of
come in waves
uh as a result of the isolation and
the um inability to kind of plan for the
future
and have things to look forward to like
i'm trying to not
discount that because i think that those
things are very real
and you know in in what you just related
i'm
i'm my mind returns to another theme
from
eisenstein's uh essay
which is this forced moment of repose
being an opportunity for us to
re-evaluate reassess the systems
that are broken right now the systems
that led to
a novel virus appearing to the extent
that it did in the first place
you know why um you know we're in a
society where there are so many
comorbidity factors among too many
people you know what is going on with
how we structured our society that has
created so many
ills that require our redress at the
moment and i'm not seeing
a lot of discussion about that either
and i feel like that's a missed
opportunity
and you know if we can identify
a gift in all of this and that was
really at the core of what eisenstein
was trying to say
it's this opportunity to make some
fundamental changes
yeah i couldn't agree more and
like i think it depends
you know on who you are how you've
experienced
this this lockdown this pandemic
but i honestly would say and and i've i
have
worked uh for much of my career in sort
of
quite deprived areas uh with people of
sort of
so-called low socio-economic status and
you know what there is very much this
narrative oh it's okay for some
right it's all right for some of us
but i think we've got to be very careful
with that line of thought so
let me let me just expand it out for a
second and then i'll bring it back in
when we talk about let's say lifestyle
medicine how we can use
lifestyle to help not only prevent
getting sick
but also potentially help treat certain
conditions certainly trying to improve
them
there's this big sort of thing in the uk
recently where it's like oh this is
you know this is classist it's all right
for some you know
we should be we shouldn't waste our time
with this obsession with lifestyle
we should be focusing on the real causes
which is poverty
and actually um you know
the the sort of the problems in society
with rich and poor and those sort of
disparities and income levels
and again it's very much like this it's
either or you've got to choose
and it's just not really reflexive
sometimes i think people like
saying these things when they actually
haven't dealt with these communities
right when you've when you've been in
these communities
and like i have and of course my
experience
is very much it's very much influenced
by
my patient population now it could be
completely different in a different area
i accept that
but you know even people who are
i've seen who who are struggling they're
on benefits they really don't have much
disposable income
um you know there's all kinds of
pressures on them
just saying oh the environment around
you needs to change there's nothing
you can do it's very disempowering i
have found that when you
speak with respect to these people
when you actually communicate with them
when you actually listen so they know
you've heard them and you speak to them
they're open to change they're open to
rethinking about their situation in a
different way i've done that recently
with some people and really helped them
reframe the pandemic even though they're
under financial pressures because there
is a gift there is an
opportunity there's always an
opportunity to learn
from anything in life they're really for
all of us no matter how bad
and i really feel strongly about
something i'll be thinking a lot about
over the summer when this big lifestyle
medicine thing blew up in the uk
and i thought it's just reflective
everything that's divisive in the world
at the moment it's either raw it's black
and white it's like well
you can have both you can try and
improve the social
situation for certain communities but
you can also
empower them and i i really feel you
know once you lose
agency once you feel you have no agency
over what happens to you
it doesn't matter what your income level
is it's downhill
you have to and and i've been thinking
about the word in power
literally in the last couple of days i
was chatting to my video guy gareth
and we were just talking about
empowering i thought
oh to give power to like i know it's so
obvious but it the penny dropped for me
ah to give
power of course that's why i love to
empower people no matter who they are
because
you're giving someone power no matter
how small
you're giving them an opportunity to
know that hey i can make a change and so
i said i'd i'd go wide and then bring it
back in i don't know where i went
but essentially i really feel that for
all of us there is
something that we can take from this
you know and i think really we should
all be looking for that
and i've been encouraging people from
the start on my instagram stories and on
my
platforms to say guys do a bit of
journaling you know
you won't remember how you felt now when
things return
you know in inverter commas you know
whatever normal or normality
or you know whatever whatever that ends
up being and looking like
i said maybe do some journaling and
write down how you feel so when you are
back and you're busy
you kind of remember some of those
insights that you had when you could
hear
the birds singing and you could hear and
you could hear bursts in a way you've
never heard before
and where you could cycle with your
children down a busy streets
and actually there was no one on the
roads and you weren't worried about
safety and anything
so i think if people have journal they
will have some very interesting
reflections to look back on
well that's a perfect segue into the new
book
feel better in five which is about here
it is you show it here
i have it right here wrong which is all
about empowerment
and you know it's in the vein of your
other books but i i think that
what you've done with this book
and what i love about it is that it's so
action
driven you know and i think if you have
a particular
superpower that defines who you are in
the work that you do
it's your ability to distill rather
complicated and confusing concepts
that are related to diet and health and
fitness and stress reduction
and recovery and sleep by
drilling down to very basic doable
common sense tasks
and to do it with like a bit of a plum
and
and charisma so that people can digest
it and receive it and most importantly
implement it into their lives uh and i
think you've accomplished that with this
book
which is really about fundamentally
habit change
yeah i mean thanks rich um
this is you know it's my third book and
i remember when i sat down to write it
it's
i was like well what are you writing
another book for what's what's the
purpose here
what what are you going to contribute
that's different from the first two and
what i feel or although i feel the first
two were very actionable
what i really felt strongly about is
that
there's a lot of there's a lot of what
to do out there whether it's on podcasts
or
books there's a lot of oh you should do
this this is what you can do
in fact we've never lived in a better
time for learning what to do there's
just
you know there's so many options but
potentially with that choice comes
paralysis
and you see a lot of people not actually
doing anything and i
again i'm very much informed by my
almost two decades now of seeing
patients
not everyone with the information
actually goes and does
anything and i thought well why is that
and i've always i've always been
fascinated as to which
patients can make change and which
patients can't and
is there a common factor now i figured
out
early on that actually there was a
couple of tricks you can use
to help people make change and transform
their lives
but i figured out that you've got to
start small with most people now not
with everyone we can get to that but
with
most people you've got to start small
and you know
i think the best example to illustrate
it it was this patient
who uh 42 year old chap that i saw
in my surgery he he's got
he had a lot of problems that actually
many people listening to this right now
are probably also facing he was a little
bit overweight
he was struggling with his mood and he
was low in energy
you know very very common problems and
rich i remember sitting down with him
and
it was quite clear to me that there were
various aspects in his lifestyle that
were probably
at play we discussed a number of options
the option he really likes was strength
training and
he was like yeah doc i love it strength
training i get it it's going to help me
with my mood it's going to help me feel
better
it's going to help me lose weight i'm in
i've not done it since i was a teenager
brilliant and he goes what do you want
me to do 40 minutes three times a week
i said hey look that'll be amazing if
you can do that
and he goes off right so this is the key
he's got
the motivation at that point he's ready
to go he's like gotta smile
i'm gonna do this one month later when
he comes back in
for follow-up right he walks in like a
different person
so he's um he's you know his shoulders
have rolled around a little bit
he's a bit sheepish and i said hey look
how you getting on how was the gym you
know what's been going on
and i said doc look you know what i've
not i've not really been
work's been super busy super stressful
the gym's not really that close to me
i've just not ended up going and rich
why that why
that is such an influential consultation
for me is because i remember sitting
there
thinking i didn't think as many people
expect me to have thought
why has he not done what i've asked him
to do
i just thought wrong and you've clearly
not given him advice that
he feels is relevant for him
in the context of his life and so i took
off my
my jacket and i said well i'm going to
teach you a workout right now so i
taught him this
five body weight exercises modified them
for his ability and i said can you do
them because yeah no problem i said okay
can you do this
i want you to do this five minutes twice
a week
and he looked at me and he said what 10
minutes a week
i said yeah can you manage that because
yeah of course i can i can
i can manage that that's okay i'll see
you in four weeks
he goes off four weeks later he comes
back rich
and he walks in big smile on his face
chest puffed out i said how are you
doing and he said
doc i feel amazing like you said do
farmers twice a week i found it so easy
i do that workout for 10 minutes every
evening before i have my evening meal
and he that was 70 minutes of strength
training a week
right he couldn't do 40 minutes three
times a week by making it super easy
he feels good he increases it not
because
i asked him to but because he wanted to
and then he was doing that for a good
five years right 70 minutes of strength
training for five years and that led to
what i've written about that i call the
ripple effect from there he was eating
better sleeping better and
now he gets up each morning and does a
breath work practice this stuff was
not on his radar six seven years ago
right it just wasn't but by making it
small by making it achievable not only
can he do it
his identity changes along the way
and i think that's why i think this book
has proved so
successful and popular with certainly
people here in the uk
is because it works it it's based on 20
years clinical experience that i've got
but also when i when i think last time i
saw you actually i'd maybe just come
back from seeing bj
fogg in um up in santa rosa on his boot
camp
and bj who's arguably one of the world's
leading experts in human behavior
um certainly i think i feel that he is
he
it was it was such a peaceful meeting
because he looked at the book and a he
he said some really nice things about it
he said it's one of the best habit
change programs
he's ever come across deceptively simple
but remarkably effective
which was so humbling to get that from
someone like that but
what was really interesting i've come to
see
patients and habit change from
clinical experience so i've come to it
not from research
i'm not a researcher i've come to it
from what i have seen work with real
people with busy people with busy lives
bj's come to it from scientific research
and then this beautiful meeting which is
why we hit it off so much he's like oh
your
clinical experience is replicating
exactly what my scientific research is
saying
and it was it was lovely to sort of see
that and i'm really passionate that i'm
not a researcher
i keep abreast of the research but as
we've spoken about before rich
i'm about results i'm about helping the
person in front of me
if i'm not able to help them i'm like
well you've got to do better wrong and
you've got to find
another way of connecting and you've got
to find another way
of making them feel that they want to do
this
i had forgotten that you did the boot
camp with bj
and we were going to talk about that
when you were on your way over and i've
since been
going back and forth with bj trying to
get him on the podcast i think his work
is
incredible and it's impossible to read
your book and not
think about the work of bj fogg the work
of charles duhigg the work of
james clear like these people who have
really pushed the boundaries in terms of
helping us
understand how we form habits how we
break them how we create
new ones and if there's an overarching
kind of
theme in all of their work it's that you
have to distill these things down into
very
tiny actionable changes that fit
within the construct of your life and
and the way you kind of articulate it in
your book
is is by using this idea of bending
like don't bend life around the demands
of your program
create it such that it bends around the
way that your life is
constructed and when you share that
example of the the guy who wanted to
start a strength training program i'm
sure when he said oh i'm going to go to
the gym a couple times of the week
a couple times a week it doesn't sound
daunting he's not
conscious of the fact that his
environment
and the constraints of his job are not
as conducive to making that happen
as reality ends up dictating right so
the only way to get him to form the new
habit
is to break it down into a bite-sized
chunk that's so
preposterously small that it doesn't
feel like it moves the needle
at all but it creates this
a starting point and then an emotional
attachment to the behavior
and then ultimately momentum which
almost
has like this ethereal spiritual energy
like once you have momentum
these habits become self-perpetuating
and i don't know what that's
about precisely but i've seen it
in my own life like it's so hard to
begin something but once you kind of
begin that process and become more and
more invested in it
it becomes easy so why is it easy when
you have momentum and so hard to begin
that's a great question rich you know
the the sort of the magic of momentum
what is going on there um look i think
it's how we're wired as humans right
it's it's as bj talks about
and as i've seen it's not the repetition
that wise in the behavior it's the
emotion right we're we're human beings
basically what we were talking about
right at the start we are social beings
we've got feelings we like to connect
with
others and when our
when we feel good right we want to feel
that again which is why a big part is
how do you
how do you help yourself feel good
after you've done something it's a
really important part of behavior change
and actually you talk about momentum
like even if you talk about something
like the calm meditation app and lots of
wellness apps they've got streaks you
know they know that we thrive with
momentum and i remember when i was using
calm
religiously last year for a period of
time when i got to
like 40 days or 41 days i was like oh
man i don't want to break my streak
like i don't want to start at zero again
i'm going to have to keep going
we we know that that's how we're wired
as humans so i think i think momentum is
is very very important
but i think also on that theme bridge
i'd say that
it's also the way we look at these good
habits
right we don't look at them in the same
way as bad habits so in
a bad habit an inverter calm is bad
right
i'm sort of moving away from calling
things good or bad you know all these
behaviors serve
a purpose in some way right let's say
you've got something let's say
for five minutes a day contin
consecutively
i asked you to get a full fat
soft drink of your choice like
you know let's say it's a cola brand and
for five consecutive minutes
i asked you to drink that right you know
you you wouldn't surprise you would it
if after
a few days your teeth start to feel a
little bit a little bit sore
you you know you don't sleep as well
you're a bit moody or if i ask you to
smoke a cigarette for
five continuous minutes every day it
wouldn't surprise you that after a few
days you'd be coughing a little bit
your mouth wouldn't feel great okay so
we we know with bad habits we we
we see how quickly they can add up to
causing problems
but when we flip it and we look at you
know so-called good habits or the habits
that we're trying to bring in
well we look at it completely different
way we think it's got to be really hard
it's got to be punishing
i've got to deprive myself i've got to
i've got to really push it and hit it
hard in the gym
or it doesn't count and we we completely
bias the way we look at it
but you know tooth brushing is a great
example you know we brush our teeth
for two minutes in the morning two
minutes like four minutes a day
we know that's going to look after our
dental health by and large
for life and we don't do the the the
hour and a half brush on the weekend
exactly you know that's why i often say
i say you don't you don't not brush in
the week and go hey you know what i'm
going all in on sunday i'm having the
one hour deep clean today
you know we don't do that we know a
little bit regular makes the difference
and
you know what's really interesting is if
we
you can look at other industries outside
health
and see how they've got this down so
business
amazon right amazon you know
i think certainly now must be one of the
world's
biggest companies right that
they estimate say about five years ago
rich when they moved to one click
ordering
reports say their profits went up by 300
million dollars
a year i would have thought it would
have been even higher than that
maybe you know maybe it was yeah the
more seamless you make it
yeah all right exactly they get it
they they understand if you make
something easy if you don't have four or
five steps to make a decision
where each step is a deci is it is a
reason to
back out of making that decision you
make it easy
people buy more netflix future they all
do the same thing
they roll one video into the next so
it's easy
so before you have a chance to think oh
i need to stop i need to go to sleep
you're into the next episode right
i'm not criticizing those companies i
get it there
they've got an understanding of behavior
science and they use it
for their industry and i'm saying when
it's health
we we don't apply the same rules we
think when it comes to our health
we've got to make it hard but our
environments are not always
optimally conducive to making the
healthy choice if you're
walking past soda machine after soda
machine and when you're driving your car
you're constantly passing fast food
restaurants
there's a temptation in that inherent
environment that is leading people
towards the easy unhealthy choice and in
terms of
creating the healthy environment i'm
thinking about
what dan buettner does with his blue
zones project going to these cities and
getting them to
create bike lanes and getting rid of the
vending machines and
and and changing the environment so the
environment is conducive to the healthy
behaviors and the healthy choices
because his whole thesis which is not
dissimilar from your own is that
unless the environment is conducive to
that kind of you know productive
positive change
human beings because of their
psychological
you know malfunctioning or whatever it
is the way that we're wired
we're gonna we're gonna repeat the
unhealthy behavior like we have to
make it so that it's easier and more
accessible
for you know just like the example of
the guy you just use like
the gym was out of the way on it's not
on the way to or from work
so his environment was not conducive to
him
going there so you have to craft a new
solution put it in the home
so it's easier it's at hand's reach hey
i agree you know i love dan's work and
i agree right if our environments made
the healthy chores the easy choice
we wouldn't need this conversation right
right
people would generally be as they have
done in the blue zones for many years
they would by default be making healthy
choices
because that's what you know the
environment supports around them
um so i support that work and i think
yes
or you know governments uh councils
schools
workplaces should all be seeking to
change the environments to support
healthy choices which would actually
make people much more productive as well
you know in workplaces for example yes
they'd
uh they would actually be much more
productive so i think there's a business
case as well as a health case to do that
but again going back to one of the
themes early on
we've got to also deal with the
environment the way it currently is
right now and the ideal of changing
these environments i think we should be
advocating for it i think what dan's
doing going into schools changing them
creating these new blue zones i am all
for that
but i don't think it also means we don't
need to empower
individuals as well because frankly much
of the world
is living in a challenging environment
particularly now
and actually here's the thing i would
say to people control the environment
you can control
okay so you can't control the
environment outside your front door
you can make you can take a few steps to
try and limit
or reduce the likelihood it is that
you're going to get tempted
but you can't control that you can
control
your home environments um you can
what you do in your home you can control
whether you do
some of these five-minute health snacks
a day and i have seen that if you do
those things because of the
the change in identity that they cause
you then are much more likely to make
better choices outside
even when faced with the temptation
and i think that comes down to momentum
as well it's kind of you're doing these
three five minute health snacks a day
and you're feeling calmer you've got
more energy you're sleeping better you
feel better about yourself which i think
is
really important that i think that
starts to translate
into the choices you make outside when
the environment is challenging
and so i don't as i say you can do short
term you can do long term or you can do
both
you know yeah i like how you phrase it
as as
as health snacks basically the book is
broken up into
these three sections mind body and heart
and
within each section you kind of break
down a variety of different
practices that all can be applied in
five-minute
intervals three times a day but you call
them snacks
right so they're almost like treats
treats to yourself
yeah and you know it's a bit of a play
on words of course there
uh you know only one of the health
snacks
is actually a real snack everything else
is is
is not food related but you know
interesting
rich even though food isn't a big part
of this
this book has helped so many people lose
weight
right the amount of messages i've got
from people saying this program and
you've read it you might
be thinking how is this helping people
lose weight
but the reason is and i think why it's
so effective and this is not for weight
loss just for anything basically this
for any one of us to help us thrive in
our lives
but the whole conversation around
weights
is often about food choices and of
course food choices are important but
what are we seeing in this pandemic
we're seeing a huge amount of weight
gain
right huge amounts of weight gain now if
you if you look into the research
it is very clear you know uh there was a
u.s study which showed that 79
so nearly 80 percent of people change
their
eating behavior in response to stress
about 45 will eat more about 35
will eat less so what's just going on
for the last four or five months
probably one of the most stressful times
in your lifetime and in my lifetime so
many people
are facing unprecedented levels of
stress so of course
a certain section of that those 45
percent
are going to be eating more of probably
unhelpful foods
to help them cope with the stress so
therefore it stands to reason if you
help people
cope with their emotional health with
their
mental health which is what my program
helps people do
well of course it's going to lead to a
lot less stress
eating and i feel strongly that in the
weight loss conversation the book after
this
i'm writing at the moment is on weight
loss because i feel the whole thing that
we're missing
in the weight loss conversation there's
lots of what we eat what we eat what
diet should we eat what we should be
eating it's like okay okay
fine there's some principles about what
we should be eating
that you know there can be debates about
but i think 85 90
of the principles are pretty well
established
in terms of what people should be doing
but
why are we still struggling with weight
gain well we're not addressing
why we're eating we're not addressing
the fact that we used to
use food to address a hole in our
stomach
but now we're using foods to address a
hole in our hearts
you know when we're stressed we eat when
we're lonely we eat when we're bored we
when we eat when we have discomfort that
we don't want to uh
pay attention to we eat and again
i get it i i understand why people do i
i will if i'm feeling low sometimes or
feeling a bit stressed
i may go to something sweet that is
that's not because i'm
weak that's because i'm a human being
who has
who uses food as a way of coping so
i i find it so interesting i knew this
program would because i've seen it with
patients but it's interesting to see the
public
response that oh this is helping me lose
weight
and it's not addressing my diet yeah
i mean there's food addiction and that's
a certain category
of of people who have a extremely
unhealthy relationship
with what they're putting in their in
their mouth but
most people perhaps all people
use food to regulate their emotional
state
and i think most of us are completely
unaware of the extent to which that's
true
you know whether it's a chocolate bar or
ice cream or or what have you
there's the examples of you know feeling
depressed and trying to self-medicate
but
i think that we do it much more
rampantly than we're aware and a lot of
these
tools these snacks that you relate in
the book are really related to
bringing you more into the present being
more mindful
paying attention to not just your
environment but yourself your body your
emotional state and i feel like
i don't just feel like i know that the
more present that you can be in your
life the more
self-aware that you are then you become
like these unconscious urges that you're
doing
compulsively without even being aware
you're suddenly aware of them and the
more awareness you bring to that
the more you realize that it's an
unhealthy
habit that's worthy of redress
yeah many people are too busy for that
awareness they're rushing around they're
getting up there on the emails they're
on the social they're sort of rushing
around
taking their kids somewhere you know
there's never any solitude there's never
any silence they're consuming the news
and then they're worrying about what's
going to happen in the world
and you mentioned environment but it's
really interesting is when you do these
health snacks
once you start paying attention what you
start to understand how you're feeling
and you just tap
in you just get a little window as to
what it can
feel like that then translates you're
more
it's you know it's that mindfulness
actually permeates into your life so
that when you're out and about later and
you are tempted
you're like ah oh i'm of course you know
i'm i'm feeling stressed
i've not really had uh i've not been for
my morning walk today
that's why i'm craving that chocolate
bar and again
it's about then you can make a choice
with the awareness
um one patient who um slightly unrelated
but just to show you when you get that
awareness i had this uh
sort of i can't remember how old she was
probably sort of late 40s
um she was she was married she had three
children
she had these awful migraines and she'd
having this for years and
she didn't really like taking migraine
tablets that she had been prescribed
before
the bad side effects didn't really work
very well
and i remember the first few
consultations i really felt there's a
huge stress component here
you know she i think she was a lawyer
actually rich
um and sort of shockingly shocking yes
she was rushing around um
and i was trying to sort of suggest hey
look
let's look at some ways to manage this
and she goes oh you're gonna tell me
about yoga right you've tried yoga i'm
not interested i don't have time for
yoga
i was like okay okay uh let's but let's
see
not just a lawyer a very british lawyer
exactly and it was so interesting that
actually
what we agreed on ultimately um
is that we tried a few things they
wouldn't work she kept coming back
saying i told you nothing's gonna work
you know
this is just the way my life is and then
it turned out that she really likes
adult coloring books um which are
a huge rage here in the uk because it's
default mindfulness
right and she goes we had a long
conversation she agreed she said okay
that that sounds interesting
she goes when are we gonna have time and
again i started to apply with
some of the rules of habit change
behavior change that i sort of summarize
and outline in the book
and i said to her i said look okay tell
me about your morning she says okay look
i wake up about 6 30.
there's mayhem the children are running
around i need to get them ready for
school this was obviously pre-pandemic
and you know but i'll go down and make
myself a cup of tea
and you know we're of course we're in
england she wouldn't make herself a cup
of tea
um and i said okay
that sounds perfect what did you do then
she goes well i just sort of post her
around i sort of try and get the kids
right i said look
do you need motivation to make yourself
a cup of tea
she's like no i'm going to do that i
said okay so this is one of those rules
let's stick on this new behavior onto
an a behavior that you're already doing
without thinking about it so onto an
existing habit basically
so she said okay so i said okay what
you've got to do we want to leave the
coloring pad
and we want to leave the pens next to
the kettle
in the kitchen and we can dissect why
these things are so important but it
sounds really basic but it's
so so important so in a nutshell she
would come down
she would make her cup of tea and for
five minutes while she was
drinking her cup of tea she would do
adult coloring in
and she started to tap into what it felt
like
when the noise just shut down in her
mind
she wasn't accessing that at all rich
and
within about four or five days her
migraines had gone down
by sort of 40 50 percent or so and a
couple of months later
she was hardly getting them anymore now
i'm not saying that happens with every
migraine sufferer
but the point is it was stress that was
driving
uh a huge part of her migraines
she needed a way to access a state
where she could switch off her stress
state and activate her sort of thrive
and relaxation states
and for her it was colouring books
right for someone else it might be
something different but for her it was
that
and by applying some simple rules of
habit change number one the most
important one
you got to make it easy number two stick
it onto a behavior that you are already
doing
people ignore this stuff right they hear
it and they go yeah but i don't need to
follow those rules i
you know i can fit it in at other times
no no if people are listening to this
now and they think back to behaviors
they've tried to
incorporate into their lives in the past
and ask them
themselves did they follow both of those
rules and i bet
for most people if they if they hadn't
managed to make it stick
one of those things wasn't at play and
so for her it was transformative and
again in terms of making it easy
you've got to leave the coloring book
there you've got to leave the crayons
there because if you come down in the
morning
and put the kettle on and that's not
there
it's like you know what i don't have
time today anyway forget it i'll do it
tomorrow
and again you talked about momentum this
is momentum the other way
before you know it it's three four
five days before you've done it and it's
something you used to do
rather than something you're still doing
and again i'm just sharing that to show
you just how versatile this approach is
and how it literally works for everyone
and again
what was important there rich she chose
what she
wanted to do i didn't shove meditation
or yoga down her face
right that wasn't for her at that time
and that's what i've done in the book
i've given people 40 or 50
5-minute health snack options and i say
all you got to do
is choose three that's it you just
choose three
and do them and it's
i think it you know rich this was the
hardest book for me to write
like and i don't know if you can tell
that from reading it because
the challenge i set myself rich when
writing this was
wrong how do you reach more people how
do you get people who didn't pick up
your first two books
to access this more rounded holistic
approach to health that is
clearly working for so many people i
thought you got to make it simpler
and it was hard because i thought i'd
already made it simple like i thought
after i finished my first book a second
book
yeah yeah you've you've super simplified
it and i thought no
so the challenge was if in the first and
second book i'd work up an idea over
10 to 12 pages and this what my
challenge was well wrong and can you put
all of that in one page can you distill
the
absolute essence of what
a person at home needs to know in order
to do that behavior
and you know it simplicity is the
hardest thing of course we know that
trying to keep things simple
i found the other books easier to write
you get lost in your own thoughts go
down on a bit of a
um you know go on a little sidewalk with
it
and if i'm honest on a personal level
which it's a bit of
it's a bit of addressing your own ego
about trying to say look
bronken the book is about action the
book is about helping people
what do they need to know the book is
not about you showing off how much you
know it's not about you
shoving study at the study after study
down people's throat
i'm not against that i like writing
books like that i like
reading books like that but the purpose
of this is this is not a
what you should do book this is say how
you should do it
hmm i'm still trying to get over the
fact that there are
adult coloring books you should try it
it's not for me right i don't think it's
a female thing right now and
the reason i i'm saying that is because
my wife loves doing it
one of her friends loves doing it and
i've got to say in my body i've never
even heard of that
i never even heard of that that's cool
i'll check it out but yeah i mean we
listen we the last time you were on the
show we talked about this like i i told
you i was like you know i know you're a
smart guy i know you know the science
and you spend a lot of time
immersed in the studies and the research
and
the book very much reflects this
intentionality around
simplifying everything and i wasn't sure
that you could simplify
these concepts any further than you
already had like the stress solution but
you managed to definitely do it in this
book i mean it's very you know it's
extremely
practical like you've stripped out any
of
uh you know kind of the scientific mumbo
jumbo
that you would typically find in a book
like that and it is a healthy exercise
in ego reduction and in humility because
it would be very easy to hide behind a
bunch of studies and
you know establish your kind of social
proof and bona fides by saying oh
there's this study and i read that study
but how helpful is that to the end user
to the reader who's just like tell me
what to do
i think in this conversation we've just
we've stumbled on
the essence of
one of the big problems i see out there
the kind of inertia
to do things the time in which we're
living is wonderful we get
so much information right we can listen
to
podcasts we can read blogs we can read
books we can listen to audiobooks you
know we don't have to sit with our own
thoughts anymore we can
constantly be consuming and i know
there's something you have spoken about
before
but consumption is not always leading to
action
and you know you've always said mood for
this action right this is
this book is actually in many ways
trying to prove your points
that actually take the action and
everything else
follows you know i became a daughter
rich to help people
right i know that's the most cliched
thing to to say a doctor you know wants
to help people but it's the truth
and i couldn't have written a book like
this five years ago not because i didn't
know it
but because i don't i don't think i felt
comfortable enough
in who i was you know i probably felt a
need
to oh i need to i need to prove
uh my point i need to show all these
studies
i i've done that like i i i don't feel i
need to do that you know 20 years in
with the experience of seeing tens of
thousands of patients
i know what works i've seen it time and
time again i've seen
human beings with busy lives make change
and not make change and i've seen a
certain
level of consistency with what those
things are
and so the goal has been write a book
that helps people take action
and i've been blown away by the impact
rich because this book now not only
is it being the most successful of all
my books but it's getting into all
different walks of life so you know
like i've done lots of uh well-being
talks online
over lockdown to big companies like
facebook and europe and all kinds of
things
who are using this program with their
employees but i've got schools so many
schools have approached me
since the book came out in january
they're implementing this
in that in in in schools which is so
gratifying for me to see as a parent of
two young children
and and what are the obstacles what what
are most obstacles for most well-being
programs or
for most schools what would they say the
two biggest obstacles are to make change
number one time we don't have time we
don't have time with the curriculum
number two money well i've taken them
all off the table rich because
everything takes five minutes and pretty
much
everything in the book is free right and
again that's something i'm super
passionate about
we want to talk about wellness being
accessible to
everybody not just the affluent
well actually i challenge anyone to say
that this
is a classist book i've used these same
principles
when i was in an inner city practice at
oldham when people run benefits with
huge
immigrant population with loads of
pressures and they work
i've used those five-minute workouts
with them i've used those five-minute
breathing exercises with them
i've used those five-minute yoga flows
with them they work those people will do
them even though they don't have much
money
but i've got busy you know ceos running
companies who
who are also using it it is it is
universal
because there are so many options there
but when
if you really keep in your head as an
author really in that book rich and feel
question five
every time i was writing i was like does
that need to go in
is are you indulging yourself a little
bit here
and i was being harsh only as a as a
discipline says go i want this book to
feel different i want it to be
oh wow i can do this and i didn't
realize when i wrote it
actually uh rich you know as a doctor
you would think this as a health book
but it's only in the last few weeks
as i've been reflecting because i had
three weeks off social media during
august actually
where i had a lot of insights and a lot
of i sort of went inward a bit and
really started to think about
all kinds of things and i thought this
is actually an identity change book
because the actions you take determine
your identity
often we we have a certain identity
based upon the way our life is
but until we take action you know that
patient i mentioned at the start of this
conversation
right he initially
comes in one month later having been
unable to go to the gym
he's a failure in his own mind he's like
he's his whole identity is one of
someone i can't follow health plans
nothing ever works for me
you know i've tried this book i've tried
that plan nothing works
hold on i flip it make it easy with him
make it achievable and
actionable next time he comes in he's
like a few foot
taller he's bouncing he's got a smile on
his face
now he's not only done what i've asked
him to do he's superseded it now he's
taken on the identity
of someone who's successful someone who
can make behavior change
and i think that's the power when you
take action
willingness also plays an important part
in
in this of course i mean if he was not
willing to
do anything different then nothing is
going
is going to change right like somebody
has to have an impulse or a desire
to improve their life and to get out of
their comfort zone a little bit even if
it's only just
slightly and the book is really oriented
around
you know emphasize emphasizes the the
slight nature of
of all of these practices to make them
inherently
doable and accessible and replicable
no matter who you are and and i like
that about it i mean i think
you know i got flamed on on social media
recently because i put out
a little video or there was a a little
discourse that i had in a recent podcast
around self-help books and i chose a
admittedly inflammatory title saying you
know you should stop reading self-help
books
not because i don't think self-help
books don't have value
but really my point was the information
is not the problem there's a bazillion
books out there
everything you need to know about how to
change your life how to improve your
mindset your body your health your
fitness
it's been written and we can refine that
and there's always new ideas and that's
all
grand but ultimately it's useless
unless you can implement those changes
into your life to translate
what the words on the page into action
and i think what you've done in this
book is is
is create that accessibility which is
fundamental i mean that's the key if you
can't make that translation
then it's of no value
yeah it's about taking action it's about
you know it's about
doing something it's it's about people
listening to this conversation at the
end of it
not hopefully enjoying it hopefully
feeling inspired in some way hopefully
getting some
new bits of information or a reminder of
certain bits of information
but then it's what are you going to do
what are you going to do on the back of
this
you're going to keep walking keep you
know keep driving
are you going to just go back to your
life are you going to go that's
interesting
is there one thing that i can take from
that
and apply because that's really
that's really where the change comes um
it's i mean i'm so i'm really passionate
about this rich because
i don't think these things are as hard
as we think they are and actually there
is a lot of information out there
but that's the what right what to do not
how to do it like and look i love
bj's work i love james claire's book
atomic habits it's fantastic
right really really great stuff where i
think mine
is is different the clearly mine is very
different book it's it's
it's very practical it's very much like
let me distill it down into the essence
the six rules of behavior change
but actually show you what you can do
and i really think that tooth brushing
analogy
is really important for people right
because
i i with i've split health into mind
which is mental health body physical
health and
heart which is what i call connection
and emotional health
and if you look at it another way
every person listening to this is giving
their dental health four minutes of
their time a day
but how much time are you giving your
mental health each day your physical
health
and your emotional health are they not
also worth
four minutes you know is are they not
worth the same level in care
toothbrushing the ultra the ultra
endurance athlete inside of me is
offended by that
but well you know because i'm like i'm
like the
it has to be a big grand gesture you
know it's like that's what gets me
excited like i'm gonna change
every and i don't always succeed but i
have i'm more of the mindset that it
needs to be difficult because that's
what gets me emotionally
engaged i'm just wired that way i know
most people
aren't but it's a little bit different
rich
so i think you're interesting for a
couple of reasons so
firstly i would say that for some people
as i said at the start i said some
people don't need to start small
now those people i've observed in my
practice and i i would imagine youtube
an example of this
where something so big and so
significant has happened whether it's
chest pain going upstairs when at a
certain age
whether it's a bereavement uh losing a
job losing a house some significant
life event that suddenly causes you to
reframe everything sure
they can turn around and change their
lives you can harness that there's a
potential energy in that that can be
harnessed for some dramatic change and i
get that and i accept that so if that is
if if you are currently in that
situation fine but shortly but for most
people who are not at that extreme where
they haven't yet
got to the point where i i've got to do
this
actually i'm rock bottom unless i change
things are going to be really bad
um i think starting small is really
really
valuable and really important now the
other thing i would say
now i think i heard on a recent podcast
of yours that you have started strength
training
is that right you've started going to
the gym and that was an example i wrote
it down i was going to share with you
that that i have started very slowly
in tiny little chunks and i'm now in
week three
i've got a little bit of momentum and
i'm able to show up for it
in a pretty fluid way and i'm starting
to
increase my bandwidth like the the
amount that i'm doing
but i did have to start very small to
begin that habit shift
and i think it depends on it depends on
what aspects of your life you're talking
about so
someone could look at you from the
outside and go oh man you're a super fit
guy you're a
you know plant-powered wellness
advocates you
run ultramarathons you've been called
one of the fittest people in the world
yeah
they could look from the outside to go
he's got everything licked what does he
need to worry about his health and
wellness for but then
you could also go well is witch
covering all his bases is he looking
after his emotional health is he looking
after his mental health
is he looking after the muscle the
muscles on his body which are even more
important as
as he and as all of us age because then
you could go well hold on a minute maybe
rich's
and again i don't mean to make this
personal i'm just using it you don't
mind do you
no no no you could you could say okay
richard's eating
you know plant-based food lots of whole
foods
he's running and going on his bike but
is he neglecting his muscles
could this program for you four years
ago
uh if you did like well i strength train
every day but not at the gym
i don't think i missed a day for three
years i do a five minute workout
every day now sometimes i do more right
but often i'll just do those five
minutes and it's part of my morning
routine i make coffee
i put my timer on before i plunge the
cafeteria it goes on for four or five
minutes and
in that time i will do bodyweight
exercises or kettlebell swings or
something because it's all
there in my kitchen set up i do it in my
pajamas i don't need to get changed
there's no friction between me
and doing that behavior i come into my
kitchen
i don't need a reminder to make my
coffee it's you know i don't need
my pa to call me and say hey you've got
to make coffee in the morning no i'm
going to do that
so that's part of my life now some days
if i've got time yeah
i'll go and rock out 40-minute workouts
i might go for a run
i might go for a swim but it's my tooth
brushing
for my strength it's that five minutes
every day
little often consistency and i would
argue
potentially that had you for example
implemented something like that four
years ago maybe there would be less of a
need now to go right i've got to go and
sort
out strength and go to the gym now i've
been presumptuous because i know every
aspect of your life
but what the point i'm trying to make is
we've all got our
strengths the things we like doing and
often we
we all of us myself included neglect the
weak spots yeah
and one of the things that's been really
gratifying since the book came out a lot
of people have contacted me and said
you know what in fact the lady who
helped me design the book um
she she said to me said what you i've
always thought
i was really fit and well you know i do
pilates regularly i walk every day
but that section on heart
i do nothing like i'd literally do
nothing and
since since working on the book she's
started to
phone a friend every evening and she
can't get them she sends them a really
personal uh message on text or whatsapp
and she has said to me when it's
transformed the way i feel
my other behaviors i engage in that i'm
trying to stop
are almost just falling by the wayside
because
i'm addressing my heart's health my
human connection side of health
and so she was fit in inverted commerce
because
you know weight's good she's done
pilates she's doing all the things that
we think and associate with wellness
but there's a little there's a there's a
blind spot there
and i i really what the thing i really
think is
is really um what are the effects of
what i'm really proud of about this
this plan it is it's not like bj says
it's deceptively simple
but it's very very effective because
you're covering each day
mental health physical health and heart
health now if you want to do more
if you want to do a half hour meditation
go for your life
if you want to have a long workout or a
long run or a long bike ride
as i will often do great but i still do
that five minute strength workout it's
not a substitute so it's like
tooth brushing for everything else in my
life
yeah i think that's solid guidance i i
think the key
even when you is when even when you have
the impulse to do
more at least initially in the early
phases
to resist that temptation because if you
establish a pattern
of let's say oh well when i go to the
gym i do an hour
then you feel like the next day or a
week later if you don't do an hour that
you're falling short
i think it's better to start with 10
minutes 15 minutes
and then create momentum around that and
then if you want to step it
up you're in a more sustainable
situation to perpetuate it and to your
point earlier
yes had i done your five minute thing
you know over the last four years i
might not be experiencing some of the
back pain that i'm experiencing
right now but because i have this kind
of
addictive alcoholic personality this all
or nothing
disposition i would look at strength
training and say
well if i can't do two hours i'm not
doing it and i really want to go trail
running right now so
that's gonna have to wait as opposed to
if i just did five or ten minutes a day
i would be in a much better situation
but i swing like this
grand pendulum so now i'm doing all
strength training and like barely you
know it's like
i can't get i you know balance is
you know the fickle lover that i just i
i can't quite
court you know and that's my constant
refrain and when you say you know nobody
the example of the woman in the pilates
it's like whack-a-mole nobody's got all
of these bases covered and i think being
gentle on yourself and understanding
that that's that's part of what it means
to be human rather than
judging yourself against a standard of
like well if i don't have my mind body
and heart
you know uh if i can't check all of
those boxes every single day that i'm
falling short of
some you know uh some example that i've
set for myself
then you're going to be operating at
your peril
yeah i i completely agree and i always
say it's not about making
people feel bad that they're not
reaching these things
it's it's it's like i hope most of the
things i do i
hope it comes from compassion it's very
much not about talking down to people
it's about very much saying hey look
have you thought about this you may not
have looked at it like this a lot of
people will say rich
oh i've always thought i've got to do 30
40 minutes or it doesn't
it doesn't count you know like oh if i'm
going to do meditation i've got to do 20
25 minutes a day
uh what i've had with patients before
i've started them off on one minute a
day
that's before i knew any behavioral
change science
i said okay well what what can you agree
to and commit to
i remember one lady who was suffering
with menopausal symptoms
and um you know we really together felt
meditation would really help her but she
just couldn't get it going and i said
well what
can you commit to do you think i said
what about ten minutes she goes no five
minutes no and i said okay what about
one minute
yeah i could do one minute i said all
right i'll make your deal you start
doing one minute i'll give you an
appointment for two weeks but you're
committing to one minute a day
i'll see you in two weeks and she comes
back in two weeks and she's like
okay cool actually i started off doing
that sometimes it's two or three minutes
now and then literally over two three
months she built up to a 15 minute
practice a day
the reason starting small is so
important is that
if if i said start off with 20 minutes
you know you do it for two three days
you're feeling really good yeah i've got
this meditation thing licked
i feel great and then the next day it's
like ah
you know i've got a few emails today
i'll do it later
and i'm sort of talking from personal
experience as well
and then later never comes and before
you know it's something you used to do
and i've
i've just found it to be very effective
start small keep the bar
super low meet that bar and if
occasionally you want to go more great
but the bar is all you have to meet and
this is very much like one of my
favorite health snacks in the heart
section
is the tea ritual uh which i do myself
with my wife
um and when we do it
our relationship is different and when
we don't do it we're just a bit more
distant and it's
super simple it's just this five-minute
dedication we have to each other that
each day
at some point and for us we've locked it
in because you can't just say at some
point if you say at some point
you're not following rule number two
which is stick onto an existing behavior
and you know every every human every
behavior we do needs a trigger
of some sort you know that trigger can
be your memory it can be a reminder
but you know bj's research has shown
that the very best trigger
is when you stick it onto an existing
behavior so it becomes associated
with that existing habit that you have
so
when our kids are in bed which is around
8 p.m in the uk
we will come down to the kitchen do the
washing up and before we go on our
computers or screens we make a pot of
minty
and and the requirement is for five
minutes
we're gonna sit there and catch up now
which you know the truth is
there's no timer right at the end of
five minutes i don't
i didn't sort of go hey babe i'm done
we've done our instagram's waiting for
me
yeah right no some days it's we're still
chatting in half an hour
but some days rich it'll be like me or
her okay look
i've got a ton of work to do uh let's do
it
but i i can't stay too long but and
that's fine and sometimes it's three
four minutes it's just
that's how you create the habit that's
how you create the streak
that's how you build the momentum if one
day it's an hour brilliant
but it doesn't mean the next day has to
be an hour and and the other thing i'd
say rich because some of
your traits that you mentioned there
i i kind of relate to maybe not in the
same extreme
or i don't perceive them into the same
extreme but i have
you know certainly in my life been
pretty
back and forth with certain things you
know a lot of my friends
would say over and over again you have
got such an addictive personality i'm
either all in
or i'm all out and you know they often
say authors write the books that they
need to write for themselves so maybe
there's an
element of that in this as well but i
have found in my own life
this has really helped me when i've kept
it small and i've kept it consistent
it's
it's the bedrock upon which everything
else
sits so it's not like i don't like going
all in and making a big challenge
like you know doing a big swim run that
i've never done before i love that
as much as the next person but at the
same time
i have learned for me that having those
three health snacks a day just as that
it's the bedrock it's like my
toothbrushing it's like these are the
consistencies these are part of my day
like it's just as much it's it's not a
negotiable
it wasn't negotiable at first but when
when it's built in
and it's a new habit that's when things
start to change because i don't have to
think about them and look if you go in
my kitchen right now there are four
charts on the wall so i've got my charts
because every time i do them i tick them
because that's a key part to celebrate
your success some
some way of wiring in that behavior so
at the start of the year
i chose my three health snacks my wife
chose her my two kids
chose theirs now they're all a bit
different because
you know it's about choosing the ones
that resonate with you but this has been
very very effective with my children
right so they are that's cool
meditating every day now only for two
minutes
right and i'm not saying that because
i'm suddenly super dad
not at all i have been for me it's
obviously
if i'm writing a book on this stuff why
would i not want
the nearest and dearest to me to
understand this stuff and experience it
so but they've got it and they tick off
each day they've got these beads
that my uh that their grandparents gave
to them which are these indian sort of
molly's mother bees yeah like you i've
seen you i don't know if you've got them
on your wrist
i don't i had them on yesterday i don't
talk about it exactly but they've got
that then
they just do a few cycles of those each
morning
uh they i can't remember what the kids
have got but you know that the heart
snack is the gratitude one that we do
around the dinner table but they take
them off and they like ticking it so
it's not the benefit that daddy has told
them about
that they'll get from it they like
getting their ticks right
and that's how they're create look again
like every parent i'm trying to do the
best i can
i don't know if this will lead to them
doing this when they're adults i hope
it does um but i'm hoping
i'm really trying to instill in them i
remember actually at the end of boot
camp with uh with bj
he asked everyone in the group okay so
what are you gonna go and do
with this stuff like everyone went round
there was only i think eight or ten of
us there
and i said i'm gonna teach them the fog
behavior model as soon as i get home
i'm like what better skill could there
be than to teach my children
how human behavior works you know how
what
what are the three components that every
human behavior needs you know
and i i i i i don't mean to keep going
on about this rich but
the the point is is that a lot of people
will hear this
and they won't apply it right i say
people forget the book right just listen
to what we've said
right think about what is a habit you
want to bring into your life
right let's say it's meditation right
fine
uh what can you commit to can you commit
to five minutes a day if you can't
go down to two minutes right make it
super easy where it doesn't feel
intimidating
think about where in your day it's gonna
go you may need to experiment is it
first thing
when you get up is it with your morning
coffee
is it at the end of the day is it just
after you do the washing up and you put
the last dish on the dryer
do you do it then before you go onto
netflix when is that moment in your day
is it is it journaling is it first thing
in the morning is it a bedside journal
in which case leave the journal next to
your bed with a pencil so that
every time you either wake up or you go
to bed you are being visually triggered
to do that behavior it is not difficult
if we apply the rules the problem is and
this is the human condition we don't
think the rules apply to us
we think ah no i'll rely on memory i'll
rely on motivation
even though we know motivation goes up
and down but amazon don't
rely on on on you know
their they've got it locked so they know
what they need to do
they're not like humans it's like no
we're a machine make it easy people do
it make it hard they don't
the other thing is the the book really
doesn't talk about breaking bad habits
it's all around
forming new good habits right it's
almost like
forget about the bad habits the more you
focus on
creating new good habits the more you'll
crowd out those bad habits so
you know one thing i'm curious about
with you is like where's
you know in this whack-a-mole kind of
analogy
of trying to you know cover all your
bases like where's the blind spot for
you like where's the weakness like
what's the hurdle or the challenge
that continues to trip you up that
you're trying to work on right now
yeah honestly my sugar consumption
has gone through the roof over the last
two or three months
that's the truth uh and
i think it's you know it's it's funny
like i you talk about breaking bad
habits so one of my rules around that
is just as you want to make an easy
behavior
behavior you want easy to do make a
behavior you don't want
hard to do and that generally
works right but something's happened in
lockdown for me
um and i and i i
sort of it comes down with some sort of
i think
emotional stuff that i'm processing and
sort of trying to go through as well as
the stress
of the situation the the lack of
you know travel and interacting with as
many people as you
you know i love my wife and my kids and
it's been great to see them
so much but i really think i've missed
seeing other people out with that and
bouncing off and actually
coming back to their home interactions
with a bit more freshness
you know and i realize that when i go
out for walks
or a jog you know it's almost like my
little treat to myself i'll stop
somewhere and get some
you know what you guys are called candy
some sugars and
look i know this stuff ain't helping me
yet i'm unable to resist
in that moment right so uh and again it
might sound oh
you know poor you with your sugar no i'm
not i'm not complaining i understand
what's driving it i understand that i've
got
um quite a few things have come up for
me during lockdown
uh in terms of you know i i've been on
this sort of personal growth journey for
about seven years or so i
i do uh i do see a therapist
uh with regularity not because i
had you know like a inverted commas a
problem per se
but more because i'd like to understand
myself better i like to understand
what's driving my behaviors why do i
react to certain things why do i not and
i found it
the best journey i've ever taken is
going on this self-discovery journey and
i think
a lockdown has supercharged that for me
so i've really been dealing with a lot
of
um stuff from my early childhood the way
i was brought up the way
i feel love was expressed to me
as a child and i think back to thinking
how i dealt with it then and we had a
we had this um we had this
this tin this big box of sweets at home
and it's all starting to fall in that
i've sort of programmed my response to
stress
has been to soothe it with sugar and
for some reason you know i had a really
good few years where
i was you know i wasn't really getting
tempted i wasn't really finding it but
it's really slipped back
um and i'm really trying to uncover what
that is
and i'm making good progress i do a
formal therapy called ifs which called
internal family systems
which i've found just fantastically
helpful
and i've got to say it has changed in
the last couple of weeks now i don't
know if that'll be long lasting or not
but
honestly the the problem at the moment
for me
is probably sugar and
interesting yeah i think if you haven't
heard of that mode
of therapy before what is that
specifically so
there's a therapist uh i've been seeing
who
i really respect so it's called i said
ifs it's called internal family systems
i'm gonna say rich this is this may
surprise you but this is the
one area of my life that i've just gone
on trust
so i have not researched the hell out of
this thing
i've not gone in i purposefully
god you know what i'm gonna trust the
process the guy who i see
says he thinks it's gonna be really good
for me i've just gone okay cool i trust
you if you think it's gonna help me i'm
doing it
and it's been transformative so
effectively so
i don't know how it is sold i don't know
what the the brochure says because i'm
purposefully
not looking because my personality if i
start looking
i'll go on a deep dive i'll spend every
day looking at youtube videos
i'll get the books on it i will suddenly
try and go oh is this the right therapy
is it the wrong
one the whole purpose you have to just
yeah you have to give
yourself over it's the it's the openness
that is the portal to the healing
exactly so maybe it ain't even the ifs
maybe it's the attitude i'm bringing to
it which is one of acceptance
but it's but essentially in the sessions
that i have done
um you basically you know you you
you sort of get into this sort of um i
wouldn't say this states you sort of
they talk you through it you close your
eyes you try and tap
in almost step outside your body
and so you're actually observing from
the outside
and then it's almost trusting what's
going to come up and whatever comes up
you start talking about
and so recently a situation came up
um from early in childhood
and you go back into that you you try
and experience what was going on and
then what's really interesting and i
think where it changes is that
you know 42 year old rongan goes
back into that scene with let's say
seven-year-old wangan
and introduces himself and you know
explains who i am
that i've come here to help um
really sits down like a friend
understand what's happened can observe
it
can can relate to what's been you know
how
seven-year-old me is feeling go through
that have a conversation
and you there's a there's a mechanism
there's a there's a process of wrapping
that up and
making peace with that situation
which happened right which was a real
situation
and i'm sure this is a similar theme to
the sort of thing people do in other
treatment modalities but this is just
the way i've done it
and then you come out of it you might
revisit it yourself for a few days but
you make peace with it
and then you sort of um you close it off
a certain way that the therapist guides
you
through and i have found i've had some
profound
like i can't believe sometimes that i'd
be really worried stressed out something
was really really bothering me
you'd do that and the next day of the
day you'd wake up like a different
person feeling
calm grounded not getting triggered by
things and
i i really feel generally speaking
until this little sugar thing recently
which i actually think is a good thing
because if i'm honest i think
i mean i always think i'm getting to the
core of the problems and then until you
until you've you've healed that and then
you that you find oh there's a few more
layers of this i mean to go through
right but the idea is is is deflating
these triggers like revisiting
the traumatic event walking through it
trying to understand the origin story
behind
some of these unhealthy behaviors and
stripping them of their power by making
peace with it in this kind of
dickensian ghost of christmas past way
yeah exactly and you know
i've loved it i've loved it because it's
improved not only how i feel about
myself a lot of my
addictive tendencies in the past
they've gone not because i'm trying to
avoid them
but because i no longer feel the need to
engage in them
so you know before they serve the role
but because
some of that stuff is getting healed
right well i have no reason to
actually engage in that behavior anymore
and i've it's improved not only how i
feel about myself it's made me a better
father i'm
much more closer and connected with my
wife having sorted out some of this
stuff myself i feel i'm a better
i think i'm a much better doctor i feel
i'm better able to
you can really see these patterns in
patients now so
clearly and i i really feel a lot of the
time with patients now i go to the
emotional stuff
a lot earlier than i used to because you
can see the root
of what's really going on here um
and it and it's and it's you know even
even you mentioned when you got uh what
was the word you used you got flamed on
social media recently i love that
that used to language you got flamed
i've never i've never i've never used
i've never heard it like that
but i don't really
i don't generally get triggered on
social anymore in the way that i used to
and i'm convinced that it's a lot to do
with healing me and healing my
insecurities because you know the
reality is if i'm fully secure in what
i'm doing
fully secure right which i'm not right
i'm guessing there
i'm better than i was but i wouldn't say
i'm like completely zen
with everything you know and i i don't
need anyone's approval anymore or
anything i'd like to think that's
happened and it's much
better but i know there's still work to
do but now i don't really get triggered
i'm able to
you know as the victor frankel quote
goes about you know between stimulus and
space as a gap and in that space is
awareness and
in that awareness it's choice you know
he words it much
more beautifully than that but i really
feel i'm able now to
take a beat be outside the situation and
go ah
that you know is there any truth in what
they've said well not for me okay cool
fine um oh they may be having a bad day
they're taking out on me they think they
know me because they hear me on my
podcast or they
see me on tv but they don't really know
me me
like it's their perception of who i am
and i i i it's i just find myself freer
i don't find myself getting as upset
even you know relating back to the
pandemic
i find myself able to be a much a much
better detached observer
than i think had the pandemic hit two or
three years ago i think i would have
got caught up in a much bigger roller
coaster
than now and actually one thing i will
say about this pandemic
that is something i spoke to gabor mati
about the start
i i i sort of invited him back onto my
show to talk to him about it and
i said to gabor that i wonder if these
emotions that many of us are feeling
are really new emotions because to me it
feels like we're
being stress tested we're stress testing
ourselves in the sense that this
pandemic is now a stress test all these
emotions that are coming out for us
really new or are we just being put
under so much stress that any weakness
is being exposed very much like a
hamstring strain
right that if you walk around you may
not feel it but it's
you may not feel that on a 5k run but on
a 10k run
maybe you start to feel it it's not as
if that just miraculously happened
that the imbalance was probably already
there
but your body was never being stressed
to the degree where it showed up
and i find that quite interesting
because sometimes i sort of feel
that some of this stuff must be new but
other times think well is this
just deep insecurity that was already
there
that now is being properly exposed which
goes back to what you said about this
being an opportunity because if you look
at it through that lens
like well isn't this an incredible
opportunity then right shining a light
on something that needs
redress and here you are it's right in
your face and
now is your moment to heal it yeah
so yeah i mean i think with this started
off is what i'm struggling with it's
sugar consumption but i think that's
going to get
uh i'm the long answer exactly
i don't know how we got here but it was
i kind of lost myself in that but it's
it was it was
that's all right man that's your vibe
i've i've given you the long leash and
you're running with it i knew that
that's
the way this conversation would go and
that's why i love you brother
um let's uh let's uh i have one more
thing i want to ask you before i let you
go which is
how is the swim run stuff going have you
been able to
keep that up yeah so that's
that's interesting so um at the start of
the year
in january when i was on the book tour
in the uk
uh i was on the chris evans breakfast
show and i know chris came out and spoke
to you
and chris challenged me on air to do the
london marathon
um which i had no idea he was going to
do
and i accepted so it was about i think
we had about 12 or 14 weeks to go
yeah um and i was like oh my god how am
i gonna
am i get a train for this and do a book
tour um
so i had started training a little bit
now i was actually getting a hamstring
strain
i was really struggling uh to run
and then obviously that got postponed
till october now it's actually it's not
happening
anymore but what was really interesting
is that in july
um i got invited to bantam which is
where i did my very first swim run
and there was a few of us doing this
kind of it was a secret adventure i
didn't know what
what it was going to be it was going to
be a swim run down the coast
wild camping overnight and a swim run
back right
anyway i went
was that the thing that that ross edgely
went to also
no ross actually unfortunate ross was
meant to be coming but he couldn't make
that one
uh for the first reason then
unfortunately but it was
again one of my most incredible 24 hours
of the year it was
actually i don't think i've ever
traveled that distance so it was it was
pretty much a 20k swim run
down the coast uh we we wild camps that
i'd never done
anything like that actually so i was a
bit scared i didn't sleep at all
um and then we did a 20k back
and i found it easy i like i i really
enjoyed it i had no idea that
i could cover you know 37 to 40k
swimming and running i like if you'd
gone back a year and a half ago or even
a year ago
a year ago when i did the first swim run
that was it was 12 months ago when i
i couldn't even swim 100 meters without
having a panic attack well i don't think
you'd ever put a wetsuit on until the
day of the race right so
correct yeah the learning curve the
learning curve but yeah but this goes
back to what i
i am quite an extreme person you know i
will sometimes do stuff like this and be
like
okay yeah fine let's go let's go all in
and see what happens
and it was an incredible experience rich
because i got everything i got the first
time
but it was effortless i really it was so
different from when i first did it
i enjoyed it like there was no we went
timing we went racing it was like eight
people
you know after these covered pandemic
times
getting together and moving down the
coast
the weather was outstanding it was about
as beautiful a british summer day as you
could have
it was warm the sunset the sunrise was
just incredible
and it was just awesome and when i saw
the distance the day after because i
wasn't wearing a gps or anything i was
just like i'm just going to trust these
guys i'm just going to go
where i'm being taken i thought wow you
covered 40k
that's just i didn't think i could do
that so
that was really really interesting for
me and i have actually been working
remotely with this running coach over
locked down
and i've got to say rich this is lady
called helen hall
who i have had access in my life
particularly the last years to really
good coaches and various different
strands in life this lady is something
special
like really i've never come across
someone with this sort of caliber she
running coach is actually doing her a
disservice she's a
you know running's the name on the label
but actually
it's everything it's spiritual it's
emotional it's how
you know and working with her and
freeing up certain
uh limitations in my body has completely
mirrored
some of my personal growth i i mean i'd
love wow
that sounds interesting i'd like to meet
her so is so she's not just writing a
training plan for you she's like this
sensei yeah she is she's got
um she's just incredible like and and
her story she has
she she doesn't uh she doesn't look for
any fuss
any pr she just gets her she just loves
running and she
studies the human body and how it moves
and she's got this amazing machine
um which actually she doesn't really
need but this machine is a three there's
you have 15 sensors on you
and you literally just run and she can
see how every joint in your body moves
now this sounds as it's going to be
super technical but it's not
actually she just uses that to to help
you identify
where the obstruction is to the she's
actually not trying to help you run
she's trying to help your body work more
efficiently
right because her believers if your body
is more fluid and free
it's going to translate to better
running better walking
better anything right and it like there
was this one session rich which was
probably
two or three months into lockdown that i
was going through in my therapy some
quite deep stuff from childhood
and it was really interesting a lot of
things had moved in the way
in my running gait but i was still
getting this hamstring pain and she she
identified she you could see it on the
screen
my t10 to 2e12 right in the middle for
my back the vertical weren't moving
everything else was moving around it but
they were locked literally just
under my solar plexus and this is
something that i was working on with my
therapist in terms of
you know me showing myself to the world
me
not hiding anymore really being who i am
it was incredible so
i was with helen he'll then sort of help
me um
move uh if we did this two or three
minutes of exercise where she helped me
move
my t10 and t11 vertebrae
and then you go back on the machine
and suddenly my whole running gate is
different my hamstrings not hurting
it would take me quite a while to to
unpack it all but what i
it really took me back to the
conversation i had like you with sanjay
rawal
about running as
transformation running as a spiritual
spiritual practice
yeah yeah i got this was not about
running to do a marathon this is not
about running
to get a pb this was oh my god
running is showing me the limitations
i've got in my body and mind and as i
become
freer mentally i feel as though i'm
becoming freer
as a runner and she's got the
biomechanical evidence to show me that
so when these things can can seem quite
theoretical as concepts you think really
did that really happen then you see it
you're like wait a minute that wasn't
moving before now it is
it rich nets are in the uk all right so
you gotta yeah
will she work with people remotely like
i wanna do this you gotta connect me
yeah i will connect you she i'm sure she
will uh let let me connect you
i'll talk to you offline about this all
right does she have a website though if
people are listening like oh you're just
going to tell rich you're not going to
tell everyone else no no i think it's
i look you know what i think she does i
think it's helen hall
uh if you look at helen hall running
coach all right i'll find it and i'll
put it in the show notes
right yeah but she's are you uh
are you still running in the vivos like
yeah i'm working on the barefoot because
that's another thing that i've been
practicing like i've used when i decided
to pivot to this strength training
i decided you know because i've always
been fascinated by the kind of things
that tony riddle talks about
like rewilding and and trying to learn
you know a dif
a running style that is you know
essentially
more human by doing the barefoot running
but i'm always training for something i
don't have time but
with this moment i thought here's my
opportunity so
i've been wearing the vivos and i've
started really small i'm
you know doing the feel better in five
methodology i started with like a five
minute jog a ten minute jog
and i'm i'm up to about an hour now but
it's really forced me to pay attention
to my gait
and i'm using some of the the techniques
and the um
the tools that tony talks about but i'm
kind of doing it myself and
i definitely could use a little guidance
and instruction but i'm i'm enjoying it
and i've noticed
it is it's changing my posture it's
changing how i land it's changing my
gate and how i carry myself
not just running but throughout the day
hey man it's really exciting to hear
that um
as you know i'm a huge barefoot
proponent in general
i think running is tricky for people
because as you say you know
you were always training right so if you
spent a whole lifetime in cushion shoes
i think it's one thing
living in barefoot shoes and walking in
them and
running errands in them but it's another
thing all together to run and yeah for
many years you gotta
really start slow yeah but for me
my whole journey into biomechanics me
getting rid of my
crippling backache which i had for 10
years was through the lens
of this chap called gary ward who
actually helen has trained with so it's
all kind of
quite unified the philosophy which is
how do you get the body to move
optimally and gary was the first person
who said your back problem's not a back
problem
your back problem is a right foot
problem i was like what do you mean he's
like your right foot is stuck in
pronation
and that's going to have an effect up
the chain and he gave me a few simple
exercises
to get my white foot moving
instantaneously my back
is like 80 better this was
i don't know seven eight nine years ago
you know it's a distant memory i used to
be someone you asked my friends would
say oh he can't
he won't be able to do that he can't
lift any furniture because he's got
you know bad back i do not consider
myself to have a bad back i don't even
think about my back i may
i that was a thing off the past
and that's actually not that gary
advised me to get barefoot she is no for
me it was the fact that
once i got into feeling my right foot
move
and when i would then go and put on
cushion shoes i thought well i can't
really feel my feet anymore so i was
like i
kind of i want to feel my feet that's
what got me into barefoot shoes and i
have lived exclusively in barefoot shoes
for maybe seven years now like
vivobuffer shoes that's all i wear for
work for play
for working out so for me getting into
running
it was just a natural extension for me i
didn't even
consider not doing it because that's
just how i live
but i do know people rich who live in
uh barefoot shoes uh for living in
but they won't run in them they'll run
in cushion shoes yeah and i get that as
well i totally get that so
but helen definitely works on zoom i i
wonder if she can
because most of what we've done over
lockdown has been over zoom she's been
but that was on the foundation of me
having already been
in her studio and being on a machine
pre-locked down so i wonder
but i'll i'll connect you and she's such
a lovely soul and he just
her dream is to get everyone in the
world i think
to run pain-free she believes we are
born to run she feels that actually it's
we don't run efficiently which is why so
many people get
injured and her goal is to teach people
to do that
um and so so i plan to do the london
marathon next year
assuming it goes ahead and i'm i'm
looking forward to it and you know which
and to do it in vivo barefoot shoes
run the marathon i will yes
i would do uh unless something was to
happen
to change my view on that but my current
plan is to do that
but again what's really changed me rich
and i think in lockdown in particular
and it's this thing about for me running
is going to be
it's going to be about me tapping into
who i am
people i say oh what time are you going
for and honestly i used to be a super
competitive person
but i can honestly say hand on heart
i'm not bothered about the time i'm
doing it
for the fun of doing it for the joy of
actually
being challenged by someone saying yes
but actually i want to do it just so
i've done a marathon
so i've experienced it i actually maybe
it will change near
the time maybe i'll be like oh i want to
do this i want to break five hours or i
want to get four and a half
or whatever but i'm not really looking
at times because
my drive to run now because i've seen
the connection with where my body holds
tension which affects my running
and where my mind holds tension because
of course they're not separate
i want to heal all that and bring it
closer together so i believe if i keep
doing the emotional work
i actually believe that i will be
running freer and i believe
i'll be able to run a marathon pain-free
and enjoy it
that's exciting man i'm excited for you
yeah definitely maybe i'll join you
definitely for a swim run once the races
start up
hey man let's let's do it let's do it
for sure we
told you about one podcast meeting yeah
you told me about one that's coming up
next year or something like that that
you wanted me to check out
i can't remember well well this is a
this is
vevo bear thought who i love as a
company um
they they've you know i
they've helped me get into swim run and
in bantham which is very remote part of
the uk
it is absolutely beautiful that's where
i sort of did my first one and that's
where i did the one in july
they're gonna be hosting a very another
really special a lot of people who went
to their swim runs have said they're the
best they've ever been to like the the
whole experience
the the kind of the terrain the way it's
put on is just incredible
um and i just wanted to let you know
what that date is
early doors next year say hey look if
you are traveling to europe if
people are traveling back then yeah i
just wanted to make sure that you had it
on your radar because
you would absolutely uh you would
absolutely love it so
it happens i'll put it on the calendar
assuming that we can get
back to international travel which i
definitely am missing very much so
all right man i'm gonna let you go uh i
appreciate you
congrats on the new book feel better in
five fantastic
i hope that we can see each other in
person soon
meanwhile everybody who's listening can
wrong is really easy to find on the
internet but
check out his podcast feel better live
more still killing it
on the charts everywhere um all your
books
and you're easy to find on instagram is
probably the best place
wrong in chatterjee yeah
anything else no man thanks
just rich you know it's a pleasure to
come on
you know i love our conversations i
don't know where they'll go
frankly sometimes it doesn't matter
they'll go where they're meant to go
right
and um yeah i appreciate everything you
do man so i just want to
acknowledge everything you do you've
been a huge inspiration to me you
continue to be so
so thanks very much for allowing me to
come and speak to you on your amazing
platform
my pleasure and likewise my friends so
until we meet again
peace take it easy
[Music]
you